foreign
[Music]
cities put up walls to protect
themselves and threw the criminals out
so they could fight over what was left
but there are humble [__] like
me delivering cargo from one walled City
to another that's where the cars and
guns come in
[Music]
so I'm here then the exit is oh they
have a Foot Locker
welcome to New San Francisco I want to
hire you pick up a package bring it back
I can make your every wish come true so
John what do you wish for toilet paper
reply
all right Evelyn let's deliver this
package
it's rude not to introduce yourself
before putting a gun on someone
if you put the gun down I'll drop you
off as close as I can to where you're
going this is quiet she don't talk
[__] eats [__] much you have no
idea what's that is even the people
trying to bring along
This Is Our Land these are our roads I'm
just gonna have to go through Vegas
John hi everybody
I've never seen anyone cut off a human
head and catch it as good as that
I'm just gonna be fun
[Music]
it's never happened to me before really
oh man
oh my God it's DMV what's down the red
line
[Music]
cool screams